الأدميرال أوسر سرق داولات أمين النهائي
مهاجر الخوف نقع التخلي أو نانومتر
سرق التيناي 01 كلا المقاهي مدينة كييف
وأنا أدخن في إجازة في kadiru
جابت قبعة المدينة زفير الدفة
هم وحيدون yura thats anya أين هي الجزيرة
ucrania jura يمكنني منحهم الغول ن المنزل
أو أنت من ألم سقطت على الأفراد
أ. الخينة هو رجل حقيقي هادئ دافي
yura atonia بشكل حاد ucrania ظبية جميلة
لكنها ستطير البرشت باستثناء السحر
algo de من شأنه أن نفصل بين جيش أوكرانيا
كايفا فانوس وحتى صباح اوكرانيا الشركس
اختيار لأولئك أنا على وجه الخصوص
الرعد والكلمات كالعين لقتال ممتاز
شكرا لك على دعوتي لأكل بورشت
بالطبع هو لذيذ جدا أخذته
شكرا لك تحتاج ونحن جدا
دعنا ندخل
تظهر لك كيف
ها نحن هنا في فترة ما بعد الظهر عزيزي نحن بمفردنا و
[موسيقى]
جوهريا
لكن
d o r a s c a لا
يمكن القبض على شخصيات كوميديا ​​يخدع هذا
طريقة مسطحة
المغذي على السفينة وهو على القيثارة
ثواني لي ونعم هذا المخبر
مغلي
راكب 1 صور
بطارية من مكان قيادة فيونا
أنا سعيد يا غورو
لاجيما ماكين
يو أنا
هنا أغير للحراسة طوال الليل
كانت في الخدمة على أراضينا مواقعنا فيها
في ظل هذه الظروف قليلا من اللحم بالطبع و
ما تم بالفعل شراء الخضار ماذا
ترك المتجر
مثل
حصل متجر خفيف
سئل بالقرب من المنزل فتح المتجر
افتتح متجرًا يعمل في يوم من الأيام
يمكن للناس شراء مخزون من المنتج لأنفسهم
حسنًا بعض الشيء ، هكذا تعمل المتاجر
بالطبع المنتجات لم تعد
الكثير من التنوع ولكن لا شيء
كافية
حسنًا ، بالطبع ، لا يزال الجميع قلقين بشأن الأطفال
بالطبع نحن نمر
لماذا لم تغادر ، حسنًا ، هذا منزلنا
نريد البقاء على قيد الحياة هذا هو وطننا كيف لبلدنا
ثم الحمد لله لا يزال لدينا
المنزل كامل إذا لم يكن هناك شخص ما في المنزل بالفعل
دعهم يساعدوننا بينما هناك اثنان
لم نعد نريد الهروب ، لكننا نعتقد ذلك
كل التوفيق تانيا
أنا آسف لأنني لم أتمكن من العثور على الزهور وليس الساعة
لا داعي هنا فعلنا مع الأطفال هنا
انت لطيف جدا
الزهور الحلوة ، دعهم يبدون قليلا
فقط قليلا فقط لإخفاء
الثقل الذي أنت عليه الآن
[موسيقى]
عادة ، كما لاحظ الأصدقاء ، نحن نستمتع
في مكان ما في مطعم
آمل أن يكون ذلك قريبًا وسنكون مرة أخرى
كما كان من قبل
عبء على أرضنا أوكرانيا القوية لدينا
أريد أن أقول له
بالطبع انتهى كل شيء
لا أحد مات أطفالا قليلا
لقد كانت سبع سنوات حتى الآن
بالفعل عشر سنوات
تبدو جادة الكبار مثل هذا
ها هي الحرب
يعلم الجميع تقدير العالم لتقدير تلك السماء
الذي كان في السابق
كن محبا
كل قسم كل جزء من كييف
الشعب الأوكراني
استيقظ كل صباح وشكرا
الله على حقيقة أننا استيقظنا ولدينا
لديك هذا اليوم
للفرص الجديدة
تطوير قوتنا المجيدة العظيمة
أوكرانيا المجد لأوكرانيا
إنه لذيذ جدًا نعم أحبه حقًا
بورشت بشكل عام